welcome to this video playing Dexter
Morgan from tuvalu yeah Dexter in tuvalu
how many people is able to kill them
probably this is quite a small nation
tuvalu let's see okay we get a sloth
exchange type of position but West g6
this is not not very comfortable for
black quite often you get into trouble
because the bishop on g7 is just biting
on the d4 pawn
one problem is that very often you need
the bishop on e 70 f 8 to be able to
defend the c5 square if white goes
Knight a 45 and this is obviously not
possible with the bishop on g7 okay yeah
more than one interesting move now yeah
I guess maybe queen bee three attacking
on b7
my original idea was to to play em night
takes d5 but I only now saw that of
course be too is hanging at the end okay
let's just allow night xb3 so that the
capture is not not a problem I can maybe
even play a 3 Nexus twin takes be 393
years Wow
yeah this is a very strange move
satirically because you're weaken your
queen site for no particular reason at
least I don't see it night c5f is now
already am in the in the game
the other thing is some g45 but he has
some protected d5 if i go night c5 he
might play e5 is this oh it's not great
then how the same how does he respond to
the smooth
how the city of lb seven and it's not
just a pawn I mean the whole Queen
silent is breaking down if he gives me
b7 I don't see a move
yeah let's keep it simple and then take
p7 the Rooker doesn't have a square even
I mean a decent square so Fisher basics
you find a few ever also night g6
I can just I can just retreat yeah it's
a whole look who will rook or c 8
yeah well I guess I guess every move
wins c6 is annoying
black resigns yeah I it's just this is
just a bad line I mean does this kind of
position is just better a bit of a white
with them of course he he peep he helped
me tremendously with a six this is
really a really strange move and the
comp immediately goes to plus two yeah
well he cannot move the clean away sb7
is falling and you need to trade and
then everything's work everything works
to perfection with 95 he cannot even
prevent it even with ugly moves no way
to prevent it night 95 computer is
suggesting this move preventing g4 and
now playing Knight a5 you know why not
be formed it doesn't want to play before
yeah but for no protection the reason
it's still a good for what yeah this is
simply a matter of a light to be avoided
and a six is really strange this was one
of my what moments but I really don't
understand the move at all what this is
doing I mean a3 is the obvious move and
why are you weakening your queen side
like that black can for example play
this and now see what happens but a
success move you would never go here
never play alright thanks for watching